you know how sometimes things line up
coincidences since we've been up here
they've been happening more and more
it's like there's this black cloud
hanging over us
well I knew first first I knew first and
I knew that he was being you know
approached for the role of Gabe so I
sent him a text and said Jordan has sent
you a script read it and accept it
that's what I'll let you know but you
know it was an easy choice after that
and I had met Jordan for the first time
at the Oscars so having him reach out
was still very surreal there's a family
probably the neighbor family I think it
definitely was you know we had a
shorthand immediately I could only speak
for myself I definitely felt comfortable
to do my best work and did my best to do
the same which is like to help her feel
as though she could just go any
direction she wants risk and know that
she'd be there to have someone catch her
if necessary and it was a really
comfortable space yeah I second that
yeah there was just because Winston and
I you know we were friends and so we're
in each other's lives beyond the screen
and stuff like that so getting to set
together was like it was very organic
and there's a trust there I trust him as
a friend and as an artist as well so we
could be dangerous with each other you
know and messy as well and
experimental and everything and and
Jordan was very embracing of that they
look exactly like us they think like us
[Music]
they know where we are
my experience with Ryan was that he had
a musicality to the way that he directed
it felt like directing an orchestra like
though and it was almost necessary with
such a large production that so many
things were happening all at once
there's you know first team second team
there's the waterfall there's this and
different things are being shot in
different days and it always just felt
like he was conducting music and he was
always listening and every time I like
look over while I was behind you know
behind the scenes I'd always see him
like yeah yeah and sometimes didn't look
away and it's not like it was it was it
felt musical to him and then Jordan and
my experience was just very cerebral he
knew his world he knew the meaning of
things but it wasn't a didactic approach
and saying like we're gonna teach you
it's like it's more show me than tell me
you know and it's as two different
worlds but it's still very brilliant
work one thing they have in common
funnily enough is that they're both very
good mimics you'd be surprised but like
Ryan is very good at mimicking he's a
lot quieter a lot more subdued
definitely Jordan is more of an
extrovert even though he's extremely
introverted as an extrovert I'd say but
yeah Ryan with seeing the closer songs
with us and everything and yeah that
always surprised me about him
they're both I think they're both very
compassionate people and they bring that
into their directing style they're very
concerned to create an environment for
their actors to do their best work and
they check in all the time they're
extremely polite and even-tempered you
know neither of them ever like raise
their voice or you know had
not once you know and this is there's
some of those moments where I was like
this calls for a little bit of drama but
there was none except for the drama
happening in go no never ego so they
have those things in common I agree with
that do you that metaphor you know that
describing Ryan and there's this the the
the conductor and then there's also the
the coach that I would yeah describe
Ryan you know he's kind he's there with
you he's in the scrum and he's like you
know we're in it together kind of vibe I
played football and he did do some
football coach yeah
methods when it was a very guy centric
day he would do
all right cool we'll do let's do this is
gonna be the last take go hard yeah and
it still be till twelve takes Ryan
Jordan no is lying about the last time
you